Hey,
watch out for Euskadi,
huh?
In other words,
Basque Country for Uruguay,
and we are going to play them in a friendly.
Look at the players you have in goal,
have Alex in Ramiro Quepa and Unai,
Simon,
three arches,
defenses,
Oscar de Marcos,
andonis gorozabel,
I have no idea who Daniel is,
I have no idea who Igor Zubeldía is.
I know Íñigo Martínez,
I know David García,
I know Íñigo lecue,
I don't know who he is,
and Yuri Barchiche,
I think I know who he is.
We move on to the midfielders,
Ander Huevara,
Five Zubimendi,
Íñigo Galarreta,
who I have no idea,
who is Miguel Merino,
terrible midfielder,
today Hans Anset.
I think I know who Aimar Oroz is,
I have no idea who he is,
and beniats,
I have no idea who he is.
We passed with the strikers,
Nico Williams,
who also plays for the Spanish national team,
Mikel, Ory Arzabal,
who plays for the Spanish national team,
Alex
Berenguer,
I have no idea,
who is Iñaki Williams,
that you play 5 teams,
more or less,
Goretzka,
Guru Gor,
no,
No,
Goretzka,
no,
Gor Gorka,
Guru, zeta,
I have no idea who Yander is,
Yander Barrenechea,
good players,
che.
And I thought they were going to go with a selection be,
because they were actually going to play with Spain,
but if not,
they're going to play for Spain.
This is a great team,
in other words,
it competes with us anyway.
Still, huh?
I'm not so sure we're going to win,
but I still trust my country,
Uruguay, Uruguay,
etc.